[MUSIC]
I'm Rahul Pandey.
I run my operations out of India.
I'm a founder CEO of an enterprise
SAAS company, Bonzai.
One of the biggest challenges
brands are going to have is to
scale their creative content.
That was a point when I started to
think, how might we take this
challenge and give us solution to
a technology to scale.
Our customers are across Asia.
We are in Australia, New Zealand,
Singapore, and
the other parts of Southeast Asia.
That's the thing which really
motivates me, drives me to work
with this incredible team to go
along and build something awesome,
and build it for the world.
This is my
total engagement with Stanford.
The learning in SEP is multi-fold,
at an individual level,
at organization level, and
the society level,
I learned a lot about leadership.
I learned a lot about how do you
become a successful leader,
leading a global team.
How do you work across different
culture?
How do you use different frameworks
to drive the efficiency,
innovation?
That's been an amazing learning at
the organization level.
This is a process of unlearning.
And I realized there are many areas
where you need to re-look into
process, people, thinking.
I think each of the faculty members
are masters in their area.
So to me, every professor I met,
they are my superheroes.
They are inspiring me to go and
change the world.
I feel more confident as a leader,
I feel more energetic and
charged up to go and
get Bonzai to the world.
[MUSIC]